now we get into a very awkward rule to  explain on the song it's a French term  that means in passing White has advanced  his pawn to the e5 square if black had  played f7 f6  white could have captured the pawn ePHI  takes f6 but in Black's case he had made  the move to f5 not f6 white could still  capture the pawn using the opposite rule  let's imagine that white opens with the  move d4 and black play be fine both  players take advantage and push their  pawns forward if white plays the move c2  c4 notice that the white pawn bypasses  the black on and passes through capture  monthís owned by black would be to play  the move before capture see 3d capture  c3 and again another example of autosome  if the move c7 c5 which had passed  through capture white could capture the  pawn on c5 and there would be the reply